(upbeat music)
- Class, class.
(clapping)
- Yes.
- Today we have a new student
from the Earth
science department.
Say hi to Lonnie Turpin
- Hi Lonnie.
- Hello.
What's happening?
- Hey Lonnie you're cool.
Do you wanna do a thousand
page puzzle with me sometime?
- No, I'm just anxious to
learn and try new things.
(ominous music)
Who is it this time?
- Well let's just say some
students and their professor
are bad eggs and they
need to be removed
from this fine institution.
- Uh what do you mean
like try new things?
Like glamping?
- Uh yeah, something like that.
- I'm Professor Rich,
expert in science.
These are my devoted students.
Together with the aid
of harmless drugs,
we explore science's greatest
hypothetical questions.
(upbeat music)
Cat's
- Oh.
- Also known as felis catus.
Average life span, 15 years.
One of the top 200 animals.
- I like dogs.
- Nope, dogs suck.
- Yeah cat's.
- No I'm afraid it's dogs.
(all yelling)
- We need something
to take the edge off.
- You mean like a smoothie?
- Mm.
- Okay cool your jets.
What if cats became extinct?
- I would be very sad
because I love cats.
- Yeah cats are the best.
- If you say something
like that again.
(all yelling)
- Please let's not
have a relapse okay?
- Relapse.
- I'd like to run around
in circles for a minute.
- Okay but don't make any noise.
- Psst Jenny.
What illegal drug do
you think he's on?
- Oh no no, he's just
a super big weirdo.
- [Running Student]
I can hear you guys.
- I decided to meet an
expert on dinosaurs.
Who would know better
about extinction
than a dinosaur expert?
I'm going to be taking my
glasses on and off throughout
the interview, I just thought
I would warn you of that.
- I appreciate the heads up.
- Now your specialty, do
you deal with extinction?
- We deal a lot with
extinction and paleontology.
- Now what is an
animal that might be
in danger of being
extinct right now?
- The Iberian lynx is a
good one in the cat family.
- Opossum.
- Opossum not so much.
- Okay I just thought
maybe opossum.
What if cats became
extinct, all of them?
- It would be a very
interesting phenomena.
It would result in
a loss of a very
charismatic group of mammals.
- How would a cat
become extinct?
What would be the scenario for
this sort of thing happening?
- So a lot of this is kind
of speculation in terms
of what would cause
a species extinction.
- A lot of what I
deal is speculation.
- That doesn't
surprise me either.
- Yes.
- But a lot of the time
when we're dealing with
domesticated organisms whether
they be crops or animals,
you can see reduced levels
of genetic diversity
and that sometimes makes them
more susceptible to disease.
- I see, you're a dog person.
This interview's done.
- I smoked a marijuana cigarette
with one Leonard Kravitz.
- Wow.
- Whoa.
- I don't say this very
often but you rock.
- Anyway, let's conduct
an experiment okay?
Now this is an
ecosystem with cats
as an integral part, okay?
This is when we
take out the cats.
See how it's changed?
- [Student] Whoa
cheese consumption
is almost down to nothing.
- What the fuck is gonna
happen to cheeseburgers?
- Oh speaking of cheeseburgers,
I've got a wicked
case of the munchies.
(all agreeing)
- Does anyone have any food?
- No I guess we'll
just have to light up.
Who's holding.
- Oh I've got a huge stash
right here, let me find it.
- As an agent of Eastern
Montana State University.
- Here we go.
- [Rich] Oh boy.
- Nice.
- I love these.
Mm.
- They're balls of cheese.
- Mm perfect.
- They're so yummy.
- So Lonnie what were you
saying about being an agent?
- Uh nothing, I'm Asian.
100% Japanese actually, so.
- I needed to go
straight to the source.
That's right, a cat lady.
What if, okay, this
is a cat, right.
- Yes that is a cat.
- What if the possibility
that cats became extinct.
Would you be doing
something else?
- Yes.
- What other animals
would you be?
- I think I would
be helping horses.
- Opossum.
- I would help an opossum,
I've helped many of them.
- For society in general how
we would react I would say
it might be a cat astrophe.
- Well cat's have
been domesticated
since the Egyptians.
So about 4,000 years.
- So cats definitely serve
a purpose in our society.
- They do, they actually
do serve a purpose.
They lower our blood pressure
and there are studies
that have shown
children who grow up.
- Meow, oh, I'm a mommy.
- You're a good mommy.
Just don't let go.
- And the irony is,
I'm allergic to cats.
(laughing)
- Yeah but do you
take anything for it?
Uppers, downers, middlers, meth?
- Well an antihistamine.
- Who else takes some?
But state your name
first, clearly and loudly?
- Jenny Harrison.
J E N N.
(whistle blowing)
- Ah ha alright ne'er
do wells the jig is up.
I'm finally shutting down
this low class, class.
- But why?
- Drug use and I
got it all on tape.
- Whoa new guy's a narc.
- Lonnie's a narcoleptic?
- You can't fire
me, I've got tenure.
- Tenure 12 miles away.
- [Jenny] What?
- What the fuck?
- [Jenny] What does that mean?
(all talking)
- If you wanted to
construct a joke.
- Shut up!
Consider this class terminated.
Terminated,
terminated, terminated.
(gasping)
(upbeat music)
- Sometimes I think I'm a cat.
Rawr.